I have an idea for a predator movie that
maybe I'll share in another video my
predator meets Pacific Rim hey reject
nation it's Greg Alva here and I'm John
so you might have noticed that we did a
non-spoiler review of the predator one
of the things we kept talking about in
that review was how the movie really is
amazing it's amazing it's it's
groundbreaking better than the 1987
better than every alien movie kept
saying how like the first 2/3 are all
right even though a lot of it's dumb we
still enjoyed it it's still very
entertaining when it gets the last like
half hour pretty much the finale the
whole third act especially the final
moment of the film is when it just gets
just flat-out awful just really really
bad very good so I thought it'd be funny
we actually talked about it we're not
gonna do a breakdown on the movie we're
not gonna do a full spoiler talk we're
gonna strictly stick to the finale of
this movie because that's the most fun
part of this film the Bagon honestly
here's where I felt the film really lost
it when it started to just digress
drastically it's at the all is lost
moment of this movie somewhere where all
is lost and dark night of the soul it's
whenever they're at the farm
yeah as a farm some ranch that are at
sterling K Brown shows up it was right
around the time Sterling K Brown starts
to talk about what the Predators are
doing something about climate change
writers or Trek yeah they like a hot
shitty climate and earth is you know
well we got one generation to generation
stops they're moving in yeah so they're
trying to grab the best humans yeah the
the finest specimens for them to
incorporate into their DNA once they got
like climate change talk
I don't like that I don't like when
movies try to you movies like this
especially try to get more important
than what they are they're already
talking about Tourette's they're already
talking about PTSD they're talking about
ass burgers and using none of it too
much too much then you start to get like
a lot of really bad editing it starts
moving faster than it already has been
moving dialogue starts getting snappier
in not a good way but in all rush let's
get this out of the way kind of way wrap
this up everyone's cool now even
keegan-michael key and someone else
shows up with a helicopter from a new
station and you're I don't even take the
time to go how.what there are a lot of
moments it's the kind of movie that at
least for me wasn't compelling enough to
the point where I wasn't thinking about
her hand would have totally been blown
off or you know yeah that guy where how
did they get there how did she move so
far too fast you know oh that's so
sterling kate brown then kidnaps baby
boy McKenna kid can wonder the kid with
Asperger's right because he has this
ability to say something about movies
were kids with Asperger's and autism are
the geniuses of the world I wanted I've
heard this in a couple movies is that
thing where were you know scientists
believe that it's actually not a
disability it's just the next step of
the human mind I've heard from people I
know people who work with autistic kids
and people who work with children with
Asperger's a lot of times they can find
that to be a rather insulting element in
films I'm not even gonna go over that
here no I'm not saying the way they use
it here because that's I don't think
that's realistic at all but just the
idea that that could be you know the
amount of like focus and ingenuity that
can come from that you know mindset you
know do they ever say that are they
taking advantage of this Lucy style and
being like a hundred percent of your
brain you know I'd never mind I don't I
don't know Joe when they get to the
finale Stirling K Brown has kidnapped
the kid he's bringing into the spaceship
I remember having a thought of is this
what the finale is gonna be is there
even gonna be the predator anymore
because the predator is already dead he
already got his head smashed in and then
there's upgrade predator who I kind of
forgot about being in this movie by the
time you get to the finale and I started
thinking this is so dumb why is sterling
K Brown now well like a defined
antagonist of the movie why is he now a
bad
we don't need this element in the film
and who is he who is he exactly the
movie starts dropping incredible amounts
of f-bombs to try to accentuate comedy
or something like that it becomes very
lazy writing what I found interesting is
this movie decides to take time to have
a reoccurring bit about the predator
shouldn't be called the predator how it
really call the hunter the sport hunter
it's not a predator that's a sports
hunter well we took a vote predators
cooler right and it's not an element
that's explored at all in this film
until this random finale right who
because the Upgrade predator takes over
the ship he uses a translator which is
one of the best scenes of the movie when
the predator starts talking with us yeah
it could have worked I hated how surly
Kate Browns team and then Boyd Holbrook
steam starts shooting at each other for
five minutes as if these guys are gonna
have a showdown
then right after upgrade predator he
gives its threat they're like let's put
our differences to the side there was no
need for this sterling K Brown being bad
law there's no need for that yeah it
just kind of muddies an already muddy
pool yeah so upgrade predator decides it
seems like when what I gather the
upgrade predator had two specific
missions kill the traitor
grab baby boy McKenna cuz he's a genius
yes and for some reason he goes you got
seven minutes to prepare yourselves for
battle because he's the predator look I
guess you know it's not punching we
haven't done that the rest of the yeah
but we need to include that in the movie
it becomes very anti-climatic I hated
how the deaths of the main characters
were not spread out throughout the film
there's one thing they should have
borrowed from any of the many predator
movies is spread out the deaths don't
just start having a lot of anti climatic
unemotional deaths occurring because
they start being so fast-paced and there
are moments that don't hit when Thomas
Jane is in the tree and keegan-michael
Keys that's right yeah you get like a
kind of cool shot of them pointing guns
at each other which I don't know how
they have amazing aim at that point
they're both okay yeah it's really
Argyle have a good aim like that in a
better movie you might not have thought
about that they have this moment that
that could have been executed well they
could have had heart at it's at this
death scene but it's so fast-paced
because we got to get this movie wrapped
up and they are really clump together
it's like Alfie Allen gets it kind of
separated from the group and the problem
is he's even less of a character than
most of the group and then yeah you you
run through all the meat and potatoes of
this kind of movie is the picking off of
each character and cool death stuff and
really nobody gets a death nobody people
just die they don't get an impactful
moment and the moments that are clearly
written to be that they don't get it
Alfie Allen when we saw the trailer I
remember pointing out like did it just
show that we don't die yeah I'm great
joy gonna die do they just give that
away with you know usually when the
predator locks target on you like that
that means you're dead people won't care
if they know Theon dies yeah and then
sure enough in that trailer moment he
dies a second later from that bit movie
just gets more ridiculous somehow it
goes from night time into the daytime
because I just fight this fights going
on for hours apparently it keeps losing
more and more logic as his finale keeps
unfolding he gets in his own spaceship
with baby boy McKenna somehow all the
rest of the remaining soldiers jump onto
this spaceship it starts moving like at
a hundred miles per hour and they're
younger range shreds on tears like a
slick surface on it yes yeah then the
force field moment happens which seemed
kind of cool at first because the force
field moment starts going over the
spaceship baby boy McKenna's warns his
dad about it so he hides under the force
field I thought that was cool yeah cuz
he's like in between and you're like oh
yeah I haven't I haven't seen that yeah
in a brass Couture monta Rhodes he jumps
over this yeah over the top of it yeah
I'm like smart we do you cool off the
Mexican guy because we need to or
something I don't know for some reason
he's the one who decides to be an idiot
and shooting it goes let me shoot at it
it gets slicing like will you deserve to
die because I'm not stupid you all right
yeah you must have seen those two dudes
you
yeah like you wants to see at least one
option and then a moment later Nebraska
another moment that should have been an
important sacrifice moment is played out
like let's just get this over with
throws himself into the engine of the
ship and then the ship crashes what I
love about this is Boyd Holbrook is
foggy okay moving he's pretty great at
everything and then they start you know
jacking up up great predator as if it's
not that much of a challenge which made
me really flashback to the first
predator when massive superstar at the
time Arnold Schwarzenegger bigger guy
than Boyd Holbrook is getting his ass
handed to him yeah oh so that predator
fight because of steak say you know Boyd
Holbrook doesn't really get injured and
somehow Olivia Manu where'd is like a
spaceship Olivia much that was up for
pace you had the invisible ball thing
you know run that fast in in like three
minutes yeah it seems like she's really
far away so they kill the predator
whatever I'm like I'm glad this movie's
over but it doesn't at all it gets to
the worst part of this movie it decides
to pay off what is perhaps my least
favorite element of this movie which is
the storyline of the actual predators
because the whole point is like this
traitor predator comes to give us a gift
yeah to safeguard us from the invasion
of predators to come which they don't
ever bother to touch on the logic or
rationale for yeah so it just feels very
random it creates so many questions
because first off when when Boyd
Holbrook showed up I was like wait did
we just flash forward like 20 years
they're talking about his son I'm like
okay cuz it's kind of neat some weird
post-credit thing we're like what should
have been a post-credits scene is
happening here of his son he is now you
know a scientist or whatever working
then working there like I thought it was
gonna be he's grown up and he's working
there that's not the case
it's like tomorrow the kids were gonna
left oh my god this movie just
completely lost all sense of anything
realistic whatsoever don't worry in the
next predator he's
team up with Ben Affleck from the
accountant and when the predator killer
toys o goes up they open the pod yeah
and they and then it latches on to him
becomes an Iron Man like suit and it's
the worst CGI out of the whole movie
breaded Iron Man yeah well it looks like
a weird bobblehead is like awful it is
awful and it's also just like so it like
shredder from the Ninja - I can't wait
for a still of that thing to go online
no because like us whatever French has a
plan it's not gonna happen it's not yes
Roy de toute suit two years it's covered
in guns and knives and things it's just
so silly it's like it was dumb and then
it raises all these questions of wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute so G
predator brought this thing here as a
gift to us that was what he was doing
that's why he's a traitor
why was he killing so many compete at
least established that they can reason
and and find ways of predator knows that
if he was able to chop off some last
hand and knew that talk we'd be like a
thumbs up is a form of walking vacation
yeah kind I don't think would have
alluded that predator beyond killing
everyone yeah I keep wondering cuz Shane
Black was like I got I had to think of a
way to up the ante so I included upgrade
predator pardon me he's going are you
sure that wasn't a studio note it sure
because it seemed like you had thrown a
lot of convoluted [ __ ] that doesn't
really fit for this movie it's already a
thing that's out of previous instalments
anyway they've already upgraded the
predator we've already seen a bigger
crazier predator and so like I don't see
really how that ups the ante of this
movie just because we're back off the
AVP timeline or whatever
well that ending was was so like the the
suit was done the idea was dumb though
the reasoning for the suit that they
have now is meant to set up sequels but
it also makes you question everything
that took place earlier in the movie
it's a big part of what affects whatever
enjoyability you had with that first
two-thirds with the og predator that's
what it leaves you with you know it's
the last impression the movie leaves I'm
like I don't want to see this sequel
horrible I want to see that suit yes
looks and sounds like something I would
have come up with in like fourth grade
you know yeah I'm writing a story or
something like that for the way the
movie shapes up in the tone in the
tambour and everything on screen it just
doesn't I've heard some people talk
about how you know this movie seemed
like it was trying to be Marvel in a way
with its humor I'm like nah it says it's
just Shane Black I'm sorry to tell you
guys it's Shane black right oh yeah oh
you'll want to be ashamed lag movie and
also any movie that gets a bunch of
these soldiers together for a sci-fi
mission yeah really want to start to
feel like it wanted to be something
bigger than it already was is the
freaking ending of this movie there's no
tone earlier in the movie that warrants
this ending there's nothing in there and
it should have concluded something about
the Sun because I hated how Boyd
Holbrook earlier in the movies like no
gunfire around my kid but then he kills
people in front of his kid and then when
the kid comments on him he's like he
makes some [ __ ] joke about it yeah
there's never even a transitional moment
yeah it's a hell you're exposing your
look this whole talk you had about you
know I didn't want to grow up to be this
way son so I don't judge you for what
you seem to have no care of all the
impact you're putting on your kid right
now yes work for the [ __ ] government
at a lab sure you're very pragmatic I
guess you're like well he's already
exposed to it I guess I don't give a
[ __ ] there's terrible stuff man is my
most problematic part is that whole
ending alright guys well what were your
favorite spoiler moments of this movie
put it in the comments below and would
you see a sequel bill you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and hey check us out
on patreon we got full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a whole bunch of
goodies would love to have you become a
patron oject today